Russian security forces have arrested
more than 1 000 people protesting
against the mobilization of reservists
to fight in Ukraine President Vladimir
Putin is calling up an extra 300 000
backup Personnel he says the
mobilization is aimed at liberating the
Eastern donbass region where Ukrainian
forces are staging a counter-offensive
western leaders say the call-up is in
response to Russian losses on the
battlefield
Vladimir Putin's latest decree is not
going unchallenged in Russia
but the state's Crackdown is hard
nonetheless
[Music]
[Applause]
this monitoring group says Mass arrests
have been made across the country
including in Moscow
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid of
anything the most valuable thing that
they can take from us is the lives of
our children I won't give them my
child's life
Putin has called the mobilization
necessary and urgent
he accused the west of crossing a line
by providing sophisticated weapons to
Ukraine
I'd like to remind you that our country
also has various weapons of Destruction
and in certain aspects even more modern
weapons than NATO countries if there's a
threat to the territorial Integrity of
our country in order to protect Russia
and our people we will certainly use all
the means at our disposal this is not a
bluff
the announcement has also triggered an
apparent Exodus of people unwilling to
join the conflict
many of these Russians arriving in
Serbia are still fearful of speaking in
opposition to the war
because my government and police can see
it and I will have problem in my country
but but I want to say
freedom for Ukraine I I want to please
somebody stop putting
the prices are one-way flights from
Russia has been skyrocketing since
Putin's speech
and they're still selling out fast
a short while ago I asked andrash Raj of
the German Council on Foreign Relations
what he made of Putin's mobilization
well this move constitutes a major
change in how Russia has been waging
this war before this mobilization from
Russia's perspective mostly such Russian
person I was fighting in Ukraine who
chose to do so professional soldiers
contracted soldiers Mercenaries and
voluntarily based broadly mobilized uh
territorial units however now from now
on with the mobilization large segments
of the Russian Society will get directly
affected basically by force by coercion
so from now on participation in the war
for every direction will not be a
voluntary thing but something which the
state pushes him to do so this is a
major change for the Russian Society
yeah and it brings the war a lot closer
to home for the Russian population
doesn't it this is not going down well
we've seen protests already today people
scrambling to leave the country why
would Putin risk this kind of backlash
most probably the Russian leadership
calculates that protests will die down
quite quickly or if not they could be
repressed and anyways we are talking
about the country of 140 million a few
thousands are protesting in a few cities
and hundreds of these few protesters are
getting arrested so probably the
criminal calculates that it can quickly
repress or at least manage the
dissatisfaction of the society so the
mobilization can go on
it's no secret though that the Russian
army is already struggling to equip the
troops it has in Ukraine at the moment
does it even have the resources to train
incorporate dress and arm 300 000 more
soldiers
this is one of the the largest question
marks about the whole mobilization I
mean uh it's not only about calling in
the man just as you said you have to
train them you have to equip equip them
you have to transport them to the front
line the most important bottleneck of
all these is actually the training
because those professional and contract
soldiers who could train these newly
coming reservists are actually either
fighting in Ukraine or are already
wounded and dead so it's a it's a big
question mark whether Russia will be
able to provide these reservists with
the sufficient training and if not I'm
quite afraid that this freshly mobilized
Russian man will be sent to the front
line with improper training meaning that
heavy losses are likely to occur among
them
so you don't believe this will be a game
changer
actually what I believe is that by
putting more I mean additional 300 000
soldiers on the front line but
reservished in properly trained
improperly equipped it will not be a
game changer it will just be more of the
same a lot more of the same however
uh this very thinly veiled nuclear
threat he aimed at the West in his
address earlier today how concerned
should we be about that
I wouldn't be too much concerned about
this this nuclear this nuclear threat in
terms of content it did not really
differ from the previous nuclear Sable
rattling the duration leadership has has
done a few a few times already it
constitutes a bit of a change though
because ever since the the beginning of
the summer Russia has not mentioned the
possibility of using nuclear nuclear
weapons so we had basically kind of a
three-month period of a lot of Silence
about nuclear weapons now Putin again
came up I came up with this narrative
however the good news is that there are
no signs that Russia would actually
mobilize its nuclear forces Andres rash
of the German Council on Foreign
Relations thank you so much